today on the Matt Walsh show I don't
know if you guys have heard of this
corona virus coronavirus thing but yeah
it turns out we're in the midst of a
global pandemic nobody's really talking
about it so you're glad I'm sure you're
relieved that I'll be discussing it on
the show today now the bad news is on
top of the fact that it's a pandemic is
that our elected leaders do not seem
interested in or capable of leading us
through this have we gotten to a point
where our leaders in Washington simply
don't have the capacity to handle
something like this we're gonna talk
about that also five headlines including
a especially vile product being sold by
Amazon in fact it was being sold as
taken down now but the fact that it was
ever up there to be sold in the first
place I think tells you something and in
your daily cancellation something a
little bit different handshakes
have been cancelled I didn't cancel them
it's just they'd been canceled as all
hand-to-hand contact or combat is now
out the window because the corona virus
but where do we go from here I've
noticed there's a real problem of people
not knowing how to greet each other so
we're gonna try to sort through that
very important issue as well
today all all of that including your
emails why I'm wrong bunch of stuff
coming up we'll talk about all that but
first a word from LifeLock you know
getting your identity stolen it's it's
it's not just nerve-racking and could be
a bit panic inducing to go through
something like that it's also just
wildly inconvenient and it's a really
time-consuming problems to solve anyone
who's been through this knows it's it's
a really difficult problem that takes up
a lot of your time and during tax season
especially your name your Social
Security lots of valuable information
about yourself as emailed around a lot
more than usual and then that's where
people can come in through you know
through your devices that they can steal
the info they sell it on the dark web
and now you've got you you already have
to go through paying taxes which nobody
likes that getting you're getting your
identity stolen on top of it is insult
to injury so you don't want that to
happen and that's why you need LifeLock
life lock monitors for monitors for uses
of personal info it alerts you to
possible suspicious activity and if you
become a victim of identity theft well
you know I said it's really difficult
and time-consuming to sort through
LifeLock is gonna make it a lot easier
with their life lock restoration
specialist they're gonna work to help
you fix it now you can join now and I
would really recommend it save up to 25%
off your first year go to LifeLock comm
slash wolf that's LifeLock comm slash
walsh for 25% off LifeLock comm slash
walls alright coronavirus coronavirus
coronavirus coronavirus one quick
coronavirus tidbit corona bit before we
get into the meat and potatoes here I
was at a store yesterday and I saw
there's a common sight I'm far from the
first person to see something like this
at the store but it's actually my first
time saying is I hadn't been in the
grocery store in a little bit and so I
went to the grocery store I saw a woman
filling her cart with every box of size
4 diapers in the aisle and and as I said
we've gotten used to this kind of seen
people buying up all the toilet paper
hand sanitizer soap etc I just think we
need to be able to work together a
little bit on this thing and I'm gonna
get back to this to that theme later on
as we discussed this but I think we as
Americans we need to be able to in
community members we need to be able to
help each other out a little bit whether
this ends up being as bad as we fear it
might be or not either way people need
things like soap and diapers and toilet
paper and your your kid is probably not
gonna go through that many diapers in a
few weeks just like you're probably not
going to go through 19 gallons of hand
sanitizer in a month other people need
that stuff now I know maybe maybe
leaving something on the shelf for the
next guy to get it doesn't feel like the
most rewarding thing to do because
you're just leaving it for some random
stranger and so you think hey I might as
well take it but I think we need more
more teamwork than that and I saw
someone point out on Twitter Twitter
yesterday that you know it also is in
your best interests to allow other
people in your neighborhood to wash
their hands too so maybe that's another
reason not to buy up all of the all of
the soap and hand sanitizers and
everything
now I get that what I saw maybe there's
a reasonable explanation maybe she has
triplets I we had twins so even that I
understand how many diapers you go
through maybe she had triplets that
would explain all the bye probably not
but maybe maybe she was buying the
diapers to donate to an orphanage again
probably not but it's possible
I don't know but obviously there is a
problem generally speaking of people
buying up all the necessary items for
themselves hoarding them and I I think
we need to be better than that because
we're not going to be able to rely on
the government to get us through this
and that that's becoming more and more
obvious as I said we'll talk more about
that in a minute the bigger picture we
you know we discussed the virus on the
show yesterday just like every other
everybody else and I said I think I was
wrong
early on when I said this is panic about
nothing or nearly nothing the facts on
the ground have changed and enough
doctors virologists epidemiologists and
other experts have have weighed in into
this point have become pretty obvious
and I'm convinced that my initial
approach and attitude was wrong now I've
gotten a fair amount of blowback from
the show I did yesterday some people
have really bought fully into the idea
that this is nothing but hype it's just
a it's a media thing there are even some
people who really do think it's a media
hoax I think that's a minority people
who think it's a it's just almost
invented what's more common is yeah it's
real but it's not nearly as bad as
everybody saying and these are that was
again that was my take on it a month ago
a month and a half ago but for me it
seems like the reality has become more
clear the facts have surfaced enough
facts anyway and I'm gonna change my
mind I think there are some people that
they had that take early on and they're
gonna ride with it this is this is this
this is their official position on the
corona virus and I'm sticking with it no
matter what happens all the way to the
end
in I sort of understand part of that
because in some ways it still doesn't
feel real I think that's part of the
problem that it's hard for us it's hard
for me I admit to accept that something
so primitive and ancient and barbaric as
a viral epidemic could intrude into our
comfortable safe modern lives and turn
everything upside down it's hard to
accept that especially when you still
look around and aside from the grocery
store shelves being cleaned out other
than that most of us depending on where
you live but most of us we look around
and everything seems pretty much normal
and so you think well it's normal we
take it for granted it's always gonna be
normal it always has been normal it's
gonna continue being normal couldn't
this this thing couldn't possibly turn
our lives upside down but it has whether
we choose to accept it or not
grovel governments across the world of
quarantined entire populations some have
gone so far as to track their citizens
they're infected citizens with GPS
that's what that's what South Korea did
Italy you know the mortality rate is 5%
doctors are so overwhelmed they have to
choose which patients to treat yes they
have an older population yes that's true
but part of their problem I read
something to yesterday from a doctor in
Italy saying that our problem is yes we
have older populations but our biggest
problem is we didn't take this seriously
enough early on and we got blindsided
and we know that the numbers of infected
are trending up drastically and medical
experts are saying that it's going to
get much worse I don't have any
information or evidence to disagree with
them if I were to say no it's not gonna
get worse I would be saying that purely
based on what I hope is true it's not
like I have any scientific research that
it that I can put up against what the
medical experts are saying I don't now
here in the United States 1,300 reported
cases just two weeks after President
Trump said there were 15 cases and that
he expected that to be closed down to
zero very soon that obviously has not
happened the number here is growing
exponentially even
though very few Americans have been
tested I think the latest I saw is
they're doing about a hundred tests each
state is doing maybe about a hundred
tests per day the CDC has done a hundred
tests total in the last two weeks that
is not nearly enough all of these
factors I think explain why you know
organizations like the NCAA and Disney
have chosen to forfeit billions of
dollars by shutting down their
basketball season and theme park
respectively I don't think we can chalk
this up to two simple panic businesses
don't throw billions of dollars into the
fire pit for no reason they don't do it
on an emotional win now you could say
that they're doing it out of because of
a concern for liability and they've
talked to the insurance companies and
I'm sure that's the case but still they
wouldn't be forfeiting billions of
dollars at for fear of liability unless
there was a real chance of there being
some liability and then of course we
know we have states and towns the state
of Maryland shut down all the schools
all these things are happening all of
this to say that it's a damn shame we
have a collection of partisan hacks and
useless buffoons leading us through this
crisis and that's what I want to focus
on a little bit more but before we get
to any of that first a word from blink
sail you know if you're if you work
freelance if you have a small business
it one of the most time-consuming things
to deal with and I've been through this
myself because I've done some freelance
work is the invoicing you know you got
you have to get the invoicing right you
need to make sure you're doing it
correctly because that's how you get
paid but it takes a lot of time
sometimes it can be complicated keeping
track of everything finding the right
format and template all that stuff could
be a real hassle
that's where blink sail comes in look
being your own boss is great but running
your own business isn't always easy
whether you have employees or not
there's billing accounting staying
organized that's my biggest challenge
personally in life in general and at
freelancing no matter how no matter it
no matter what your what your situation
is it's a difficult thing and that's why
you need blink sail blink sail makes it
easy to send professional invoices and
track payment
in just a few seconds you can create
invoices you can send them to clients
keep up with keep up with all that until
they get paid forget about using invoice
templates or stressing about
coordinating a bunch of different
software programs blink sale takes care
of it all less time worrying about
billing means more time worrying about
the stuff the work that actually gets
you paid I've done this myself I've used
blink sale I'm telling you this just
it's gonna be a lot easier on you make
make life easier on yourself and if
you're if you are your own boss your
other people's bosses you've got plenty
of other things worried about you don't
to worry about you don't need to worry
about this try blink sale for free at
blink sale calm that's be Li NK s al-eid
comm blink sale comm blink sale spend
less time billing and more time doing
what you love
alright now keeping in mind
the severity of this of the situation do
we have leaders in Washington that are
capable of actually taking this
seriously and addressing the problem I'm
not very optimistic and it was reported
yesterday that Nancy Pelosi tried to jam
funding for abortion into the
coronavirus economic stimulus package
that they're working on other other I
mean think about that we're looking at a
global pandemic what she's worried about
is let's get abortion funded here and
overseas that's what she wants other
Democrats have spent their time accusing
Trump of racism for accurately reporting
accurately stating that the virus
originated in China which it did Alice
ager Kaiser Cortez we talked about few
days ago has been talked about how it's
straight up racism because people aren't
patronizing Chinese restaurants have
actually said patronage Chinese
restaurants with it which isn't a word
the Democratic governor of Washington
the state hardest hit by the virus so
far responded to a supportive call from
vice president pence vice president
called him asked him if he needed
anything was checking in doing his job
the governor turns around and bashes
Pence and Trump on Twitter and now
Democrats are rallying together to stop
us from blaming China that's their focus
even as China is blaming us so China's
blaming us China is now claiming that
the US US military brought the virus to
China and then China turned around and
shipped it back to us
that's the absurd conspiracy theory and
the the deflection of blame that they're
doing and fortunately for them they have
half of our elected officials in
Washington taking their side and saying
yeah that's exactly what happened so
China's blaming America and the
Democrats are blaming America what else
is new the fact that China started this
is actually important this isn't
semantics okay this isn't some
irrelevant detail like we should just
move on and not worry about it there are
other things to worry about too of
course and blaming them won't in itself
solve the crisis nobody is saying that
it will but this did begin with them
they weren't honest about it they still
aren't being honest about it they
weren't transparent they still aren't
being transparent they stifled the
spread of information they stopped
doctors and health experts from talking
about it publicly some people have
called this that essentially the Chinese
Chernobyl and I think that's a good
comparison and their responsibility for
this is real and it's important for us
to acknowledge I think but the Democrats
are running interference for them and
but this isn't just about the Democrats
and China now those groups are certainly
they deserve some of the fingers to be
pointed at them but it's not just about
them and and and I think this is the
part up until now most of you have
probably been giving me the thumbs up
and saying Amen as I'm blaming talking
about China talking about the Democrats
but this is the part where some of you
switch from amens to boos probably
because you're not going to like the
next part of what I have to say but I
have to be honest about it
and and call it as I see it President
Trump has not performed much better and
it could serve
who are going around saying Trump's been
brilliant is absolutely great I don't
believe that they really believe what
they're saying there's no possible way
they really think that President Trump
after contradicting his own officials to
predict that the corona virus would
virtually disappear from the United
States after first 15 cases that's what
he said he said he expected the cases to
be down close to zero he wasn't getting
that from his medical officials if he
had listened to them they would have
told him don't say that it's not true
but he said it anyway and it does matter
he's the president of the United States
I said I've been wrong about this too
I'm not the president
I'm a podcast host he's the president so
what he says matters a hell of a lot
more than what I say but after that
didn't end up happening of course the 15
cases didn't go down to zero he
attempted desperately for days to
minimize the severity of the crisis
because he was worried about the
political impact of having to admit that
you know a bunch of people are infected
he was worried about the hit to the
stock market which of course the
president is going to be worried about
that but part of the problem is that
Trump for the last three years has been
taking a lot of credit for the for the
successes on the stock market and the
problem is when you do that where the
stock market takes a hit now you have to
take the blame for that unless you're
gonna say oh when it goes up it's it's
from it's because of me but when it goes
down it's not because of me that doesn't
make any sense which is maybe a lesson
here stop trying to brag about the
successes of the stock market as if it's
all because of the President and then
you know from the air Trump sent out a
tweet saying that we've been plying
insinuating that we should be you know
no more concerned about this than we are
about the seasonal flu yet again
contradicting the MEK the medical
experts in his own administration the
doctors and medical experts that he
employs he's or that we employ actually
but that are in his administration
contradicting them when asked about the
lack of testing last week he bizarrely
politicized the issue by bringing the
transcript of his Ukraine call into
he was asked about the testing and he
said you know the testings are perfect
just like the call the Ukraine call and
the transcript was perfect the hell does
have to do with anything why are you
bringing that political issue into this
it has nothing to do with it and by the
way it's not true the testing has not
been perfect it's been far from perfect
now it may not be entirely the
administration's fault that our testing
is lag far behind most of the developed
world but the buck stops with Trump
whether he likes it or not just like he
said with you know the the pandemic that
the the Obama administration had to deal
with yeah it's true that the media let
Obama off the hook conservatives did we
blamed him and so did Trump now Trump
wants to say it's not my fault oh I had
nothing to do with this people aren't
getting tested it's been a total
disaster with testing not my fault I you
cannot blame me even one iota
we know that's BS come on and we know
that if it was Obama we would be blaming
him we know that we know that's how the
game is played let's stop playing to
gain there there are more important
things to be done right now you know in
rambling about perfect tests doesn't
instill the American people with
confidence that he understands the
severity of the situation then he goes
and tweets out a picture of himself
literally fiddling in the middle of a
pandemic tweets a picture of himself
fiddling and I don't want to hear oh
he's better there's old Trump trolling
again yeah III think unless you are a
Trump groupie at this point nobody else
finds it very cute or fun for the
president United States to be worried
about trolling during a pandemic maybe
focus on other things
he's address from The Oval Office I know
there have been conservatives saying it
was a great great good stuff awesome oh
come on
we know that's let's be honest but you
watched it right adequate at best and
that is being extremely generous banning
travel from Europe is an important step
not nearly enough was said though about
containment within our borders and in
terms of boosting national morality
uniting the country the speech in
content and delivery
was a dud I mean he was reading the
thing like it's the first time he read
it which I believe probably is the case
maybe take this a little bit more
seriously
it does matter other administration
officials are you know aren't doing much
better and communicating Sima versa
administrator for the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services was on
Fox last night was asked multiple times
directly whether the whether US
hospitals are prepared for this and she
wasn't willing to answer the question
watch before I let you go I want to ask
you one more time are there gonna be
people in this country who don't get a
ventilator if they need one are you
concerned that the actual physical
equipment that is needed to serve the
people who will get sick is out there
can you reassure everyone tonight that
there is not a shortage of ventilators
or ICU units and that's why the
president has taken such a bold and
decisive action right we're not waiting
for this to get worse we're not waiting
for this to be a crisis in our health
care systems and that's why the
mitigation strategies that he announced
last night limiting travel from Europe
not allowing that you know we've given
travel advisories on cruise ships that's
why we're taking all of this action
because we don't want to put stress on
the health care system okay at the time
a direct answer to the question yeah
that's that's a little concerning it's
that's you you would hope to get a
straight answer on a question like that
that's the kind of question you need to
be able to answer now we'll talk more
about this in a second but first a word
from our very good friends over at Rock
Auto you know in the year 2020 a lot of
great technology sometimes in my opinion
a little bit too much technology in the
cars themselves it becomes very
complicated there are a lot of things in
the cars that can break now a lot more
than there was in the past you've got
all the it's like these cars are more
computer than actual parts now and that
makes it all the more complicated when
you have a problem what are you gonna do
you try to go to an auto parts store so
it's all the more complicated and
difficult to find what you're looking
for well the good thing is the other
great thing about computers is that it
gives you access to the Internet right
and that means you can go to Rock Auto
comm at home and and you can you can
start to sort through this that way
rockauto.com
always offers the lowest price as
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do in other industries why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts when you don't need to that's why
you want to go to rockauto.com
rockauto.com their catalog is unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate much
easier to get around in the auto parts
store rockauto.com has everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
tail lamps motor oil it's got everything
you could possibly need for a car it's
right there rockauto.com you carried
around in your pocket and you're on your
phone just pull it out go to
rockauto.com if you're having an issue
with your car rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years and so if you're
having trouble with your car this is
where you want to go rockauto.com right
now go there see all the parts available
for your car truck right walsh in there
how did you hear about us box so that
they know that I sent you so what's the
moral of a story here conservative is
going to want to make this all a story
of Democrats politicizing an epidemic
liberals want to make it a story about
Trump fumbling and bumbling and wasting
crucial days early on downplaying the
situation whispering sweet nothings in
our ears which he did even during his
speech in fact he spent way too much
time talking about how great the economy
is doing and how great he's doing and
everything's doing great great great
great great not really you're not really
you're not fooling anybody let's be just
be honest the story though is both of
those things it's not one or the other
it is ultimately a story of a
dysfunctional government run by people
who are not interested in coming
together and a dire time to steer us
towards calmer and safer waters that's
what we need we're not getting it this
is a moment I think that calls for a
seriousness of purpose and a disregard
for political point tallying that is
apparently beyond the capacities of the
people in Washington who we have elected
to lead us and I think if you're sitting
there and you're trying to exempt one
put one side of the political aisle from
this and say oh it's all the other guys
you're being delusional you're trying to
delude yourself and I think you
so what does that mean I think it means
basically batten down the hatches
because the Washington clown show isn't
gonna save us and whatever happens we're
gonna have to handle it the good
old-fashioned American Way on our own
I'm this this is not meant to be
melodramatic I'm not saying that it's
the end of all things
repent well you should repent even even
so we should do that regardless not
saying that well this is a serious issue
and when I look at the government I
don't know about you I'm not instilled
with confidence they can't even figure
out how to get testing done the whole
rest of the world's figured it out the
developed countries and and not not not
just developed modern countries other
countries to figure out how to test
people even in this country you know the
NBA they were worried about coronavirus
somehow these NBA teams managed to get
testing done testing dozens of players
gather results back quickly so when it's
when it's when it's rich celebrities all
of a sudden there's no problem getting
the tests yet you read all these stories
I mean there are so many of them if you
read about them on social media people
who are very very sick have all of the
symptoms of corona virus they're trying
to get the tests and they can't get them
this is a problem that someone is
responsible for this the people we elect
to head the government that we put in
charge it does the buck does stop with
them not just trumpets he's not a
dictator it goes to all the rest of them
too but all they're gonna do is deflect
blame no one is gonna stand there
because there's nobody in government
right now with with the with the moral
courage and honesty to stand there and
say you know what yes I'm part of the
problem I screwed up on this I'm gonna
do better or at work we're gonna get
down to business now no one's gonna do
that they're all gonna sit there and say
it's them it's them don't look at me no
it's all of them they did it meanwhile
you got a pandemic spreading across the
globe and this is all we get from these
clowns
and they convinced their followers on
both sides to join in it's all them it's
all their fault let's talk about them
shut up all right let's go to news
headlines number one as we cover the
Democrats you know they want to make
this about racism and Ringo the Ringo of
the squad Ayana Presley has decided to
jump on the bandwagon of accusing people
of racism for not eating at Chinese
restaurants this it's hard for me to
believe that they're continuing with
this but they're there this is what
they're this is what they're going with
if you're not eating at Chinese
restaurants you're you're racist this is
what Presley had to say you know since
the beginning of the Cova 19 outbreak we
have seen not only the spreading of the
virus but also a rapid spreading of
racism and xenophobia we have witnessed
at the highest levels in fact of the
Republican Party Fanning irresponsibly
these flames one colleague tweeted that
everything you need to know about the
Chinese corona virus unquote
my district is home to nearly 32%
foreign-born residents with more than a
quarter immigrating from Asia this
painful rhetoric has consequences
restaurants across Boston's Chinatown
have seen up to an 80 percent drop in
business and I believe this has
everything to do with the rapid spread
of misinformation in paranoia it is
critical that we stand against these
insightful messages and swage fear and
our communities and we do that by
dispelling untruths and misinformation
we can only do that by sharing the facts
now we've already covered this I've
explained why it's fantastically stupid
not that you need it explained I'll just
say one more time one note even if even
if people became so paranoid that they
believed every Chinese person had the
virus and they stayed away from Chinese
people and Chinese food and Chinese
finger traps even in that case and
that's not what's happening but even if
it was what happened that would be
paranoid it would be incorrect it would
be overkill it may even be insulting but
it's not racist
even that would not be racist racism is
a particular thing that's not racism now
I think Dems like Ringo would love it if
that's what started to happen does it be
politically convenient for them but my
point is even in that extreme scenario
it still would not be racism because
racism is the belief that somebody is
inferior to you because of their race
that's what racism is being paranoid
about a disease that comes from a
certain country even being overly
paranoid not racism whether or not it's
justified is besides point it's not
racism number two is there any well is
there any news that isn't about the
corona virus dr. Brian Monahan the
attending physician of Congress and the
US Supreme Court said that he expects
seventy million 250 million people in
the u.s. to become infected with cover
19 well no that's not it that's that
still about the corona virus let's see
if we could move to number three
reporting from LifeSite news it says a
Scottish mother who has a six-year-old
son with Down syndrome has slammed
Amazon for selling t-shirts which read
let's make Down syndrome extinct she
said she said quote to target a group
who are disabled is just disgusting
Stacey Corrigan age 34 has a
six-year-old son with Down syndrome
named Daniel miss Corrigan slammed the
t-shirt slogan is hateful and disgusting
asserting that it should be treated as a
crime she said I can't believe they've
been allowed to sell this who even
thinks up an idea to design this the
t-shirts were initially spotted by two
mothers from England who filed a
complaint to Amazon accusing them of
promoting a hate crime on their website
now I don't think it's illegal I
wouldn't call it a hate crime but this
is troubling message and I'm glad they
pulled the shirt and glad someone
noticed it to have a major corporation
selling something like that is highly
disturbing especially when you consider
making Down syndrome extinct is a very
real effort that's actually underway
this is not just a t-shirt slogan this
is actually what countries are doing
including our own and the effort
invariably to make the effort to make
Down syndrome extinct invariably
involves killing Down syndrome children
in the womb
in some European countries Down syndrome
is in fact nearly extinct but what that
means is that Down syndrome people are
nearly extinct because they've been
killed
number four reporting in Greenwich Time
says at a time of near record wealth
concentration more than twice as many
young Americans say the existence of
billionaires is bad for society as those
who say it is good according to the Pew
Research Center 39 percent of adults
younger than 30 support the view that
people whose personal fortunes exceed 1
billion dollars is a bad thing while 16%
say billionaires are good for society
it's worth noting however that a
plurality of young Americans 45% profess
in difference either way this is one of
those times where I think the
indifferent answer is probably the right
one I mean good or bad for society at
one hand who cares I mean it's their
money whether it's good or bad for
society that they have it it's there's
nothing we could do about it other than
take it from them and that's the point
we have billionaires even if even if you
think that all billionaires are horrible
evil scumbags well they exist regardless
they have the money the only way to get
rid of the billionaires would be one to
kill them all which I'm increasingly
convinced there are people plenty of
people in this country who would be
perfectly fine with that plan
the other option that would be to take
their money but who takes it well the
government does and then who gets it
well the government does maybe they read
read it redistribute it I'm sure you're
hoping that but they are taking
ownership of it the point here is that
this money and wealth and power it
exists it's just a question of who has
who's gonna get it and when it comes to
money well either the person who earned
it can have most of it or the government
can take it those are the two options
there really is not a third option so
when you say the
there shouldn't be billionaires as bad
but what you're saying is it's better
for the government to have all of that
additional money in power that's what
you mean
and I think that's a very foolish
to put it mildly perspective number five
finally things have gotten pretty bad
down in Australia it seems like it
appears the currency system has
collapsed and this is how they're forced
to buy and sell goods now take a look
can I just get a cheeseburger meal with
a water alright how much was it
thank you
oh what's that sure
there's a dollar keep the change
I just needed a magnet deposit
I haven't Canada this is a lot of good
yeah
just straight hundred school dude
I just hunted all of my stuff I'm just
pretty awful awful I mean because that
wasn't even two-ply he's trying to pass
off a small wad of 1 ply sandpaper as
equivalent to $7 I don't think so so
we're not gonna make it through the
apocalypse if this is is how we're
bartering it's not gonna work
though I guess not making it through the
apocalypse is sort of the point of the
apocalypse so what am I worried about
now for today's daily cancellation today
we're cancelling well it's not really me
cancelling it but Society has cancelled
the handshake hand hand combat I keep
wanting to say combat hand-to-hand
contact to include combat is now
verboten
but I don't want to focus on the
cancellation so much of the handshake I
want to talk about what we do going
forward because I was in DC yesterday I
had to be in DC for work and I had
several occasions where I was greeting
somebody but we aren't we aren't shaking
hands anymore so in each occasion of
greeting we had to ad-lib something else
on the spot and in one case we did kind
of a mind handshake where you you sort
of shake your hand towards the other
person like this another time there was
a fist bump another time a guy saluted
me which was interesting and then a
couple others was more of an awkward
sort of half wave where you stand back
you're sort of like that Hey and then
you make an awkward comment about the
coronavirus I think we need to we need
to shut down all greetings until we
figure out what the hell is going on
because this cannot continue
it's chaos out there right now I swear I
saw two guys a few days ago touching
elbows they did this and they they both
put their elbows on touched elbows for
the greeting that's not gonna fly that's
not gonna work
so last night on Twitter I started a
poll to see if we could come to a
collective understanding in agreement on
what our new greeting will be like I
said we can't trust it we can't we can't
rely on the government for anything so
this is
this is another issue we have to solve
on our own I suggested four alternatives
to the handshake
so - so for non-contact greetings that
maybe we could agree on here are four
options number one a deep bow Japanese
style number two you kind of point to
each other and say hey oh like that and
maybe you give a a wink and a hey-oh
like that that's an option number three
is to tip your top hat and say something
like good day gentlemen
or even just ladies and then the number
four option would be a deep sensuous
silent stare right into each other's
eyes
say nothing hold it for about 15 seconds
and maybe crack a slight knowing smile
you know just like that you hold it
silent out of those options and you can
see the results right here the top hat
won out pretty big so go out and buy a
top hat we're all gonna need top ads for
this to work second place was the silent
stare so I'm gonna allow both of these I
think I think either one just sort of
read the room get the feel of things and
decide which one you're gonna do can you
combine them absolutely you can I think
in fact that would be best top hat good
day gentlemen top hat
ladies and then the silent stare and now
you really have a connection probably
more of a connection than you want or
need all right before we get to emails
by the way time is running out to get
25% off all daily wire membership plans
using coupon code never socialist this
is the last week we're giving you for
this offer and you really you don't want
to be left out all the bad stuff
happening in the world don't add insult
injury don't don't don't pile more
misfortune on top of it by not taking
advantage of this deal daily wire
members get an ad-free website
experience access to all of our live
broadcast and a show library including
the Matt Walsh show full three hours of
bench bureau show access to the mailbag
and now exclusive election insight
op-eds from ben shapiro daily wire
members also get to ask questions live
like many of you saw during the
a Super Tuesday backstage along with all
this of course you get the Magnificent
the irreplaceable the singular the the
sacred the life-changing the
life-affirming the life-saving leftist
tears tumbler and if you haven't already
heard that the leftist tears tumbler may
actually cure the corona virus don't
quote me on that
at all if you haven't already you could
download the daily wire apps so you can
get all of our great content on the go
again that's 25% off on daily wire
memberships for all plans using coupon
code never socialist so head on over to
the daily wire comm website daily
wired.com slash subscribe the deal is
ending this week join now that's daily
wire.com slash subscribe okay a couple
of emails this one first is from
anonymous this is actually a Twitter
message but it not a mailbag thing but I
have to read it here just because I find
it psychologically fascinating this is
what it says it says Matt Matt do you
follow Q did you see that Tom Hanks and
his wife have coronavirus in quotes Q
has always said these people are sick Q
also said that the first arrest would be
big Tom Hanks was in big why shut down
Italy and cancel masses vatican pedo
ring NBA players get coronavirus both
announcers but broke both announced
right after the President's speech time
9/11 pedo ring is being taken down
Harvard closes corruption watch watch
watch for more the storm is here the
virus is not being contracted by
children because we are saving the
children 98%
this message was sincere really
fascinating to me we're all familiar
with the queuing on folks of the queuing
and conspiracy but to see how the
conspiracy theorists mind constructs
connections and narratives is always
very interesting to me so queue queue is
the secret government agent I think
who's if I if I'm familiar with that I
may be wrong with it I think the theory
is that there's this guy named Q he's a
secret government agent he's on a
mission to fight the evil global
pedophile cabal and Donald Trump is also
pardon maybe maybe his Trump is cute
maybe is that the theory I don't know
but there's Q and then there's chomp and
together they're fighting this global
cabal of pedophiles and they're passing
along clues and hints through message
boards and like Reddit little bread
bread crumbs to let everybody know
what's going on so we know that Q at
some point on reddit or on some message
board said these people are sick talking
about Hollywood and then eventually what
do you know Tom Hanks gets sick and he
said the first arrest will be big Tom
Hanks was in big now Tom Hanks wasn't
arrested actually he just got sick but
still who cares we're rolling let's go
with it don't worry about don't worry
about the details we're going with this
thing okay and then Italy why was Italy
locked down well I think it's because
they're being ravaged by a disease no
that's not it it's the pedo ring what
does that I mean how do you explain oh
it doesn't matter
like I said we're rolling and then the
NBA shuts down and that was announced at
9:00 11:00 p.m. what's the significance
of that actually it's not true it was
announced like 9:30 but forget about
that don't worry about it
what's the significance well because
9/11 is like September 11th why would
the NBA choose to suspend its season at
exactly 9/11 I mean even if they were
involved in some kind of secret pedo
ring and this was tied to 9/11 somehow
which is an explained housing why would
they leave a breadcrumb for the queuing
on people to see by by saying no let's
let's announce this right at 9/11
that'll be that'll be good well because
the whole mood the whole world is one
big movie basically in the minds of
these people and this is what bad guys
do in movies and so this is what they do
in real life
see a human as human beings our minds
are really good at doing two things
especially constructing meanings and
locating patterns the problem is that
sometimes these functions go into
hyperdrive and completely override the
rational parts of our brain and you end
up in that case with something like
queuing on with people who find patterns
everywhere and can invent entire film
plots out of the most meaningless
coincidences and if they can't find a
coincidence they can always just make up
a coincidence and then create a story
around it and believe the story that's
the most fascinating thing with a lot of
these conspiracy theories the conspiracy
theorists in many times they they trade
in just taking meaningless coincidences
and building stories out of them but
sometimes they'll just make up details
that aren't even true and then convince
themselves that it is true and then
build a story around it based on nothing
and convince themselves that the story
is true to the human mind it's quite an
incredible place let's go to why I'm
wrong this is someone criticizing my
porn stance but from the right doesn't
happen very often this is from Dominic
says hi Matt I love your show so this is
coming from a fan not a hater I heard
your show about regulating poor and I
have to say I was disappointed porn
should be fully banned advocating for
crimes such as porn to be regulated is
morally wrong the same holds true for
abortion you don't regulate God's and
Dorine commands pretend to submit a
scenario where rape is legal in America
you want to follow God so you start
protesting no rape after 8 p.m. you're
implying that rape is ok before 8 p.m.
likewise with porn if you say that
people shouldn't be allowed to watch it
when they're young you're implying that
they should be allowed to watch it when
they're old when you regulate a crime
you make it seem more presentable and
respectable that's like how abortion is
in America we fight for regulations then
the abortion issue starts to comply with
them and look more professional I've
done sidewalk ministry outside of
Planned Parenthood for my entire life
and I've seen how regulations have made
abortion mills much more
professional-looking
total backfire the same will happen if
we regulate porn implementing
regulations just prunes the evil weed
while strengthening its root not one jot
or tittle should pass from Christ law or
more
morality by regulating evil you're
compromising on his everlasting word do
not teach your followers that it is
better for pornhub to be regulated I
know you'd like to see porn abolished so
stand for that when Christ comes to rule
with a rod of iron
will he regulate poor nor will he
abolish it he will will he thank you for
regulating this abomination or will he
be upset that you weren't firm enough to
advocate solely for its immediate
abolition well Dominic as you know I am
in favor of a porn ban and I've made
that case elsewhere I've made it pretty
clear I think everybody knows that about
me you you make the case on religious
grounds of course I agree with your
religious case but when you're
advocating for an actual law for an
actual real-life law that can really be
passed in the United States of America
under our system you can't do it by
saying it's in keeping with Christ's
commands because somebody will rightly
point out that making laws that
establish a religion a state religion
and a law banning porn on the basis that
it's unbiblical would certainly be that
are unconstitutional and so you have to
work within the law you can't just throw
the Constitution to the side so that's
that's it's not gonna happen you can't
if you're advocating for a law to ban
porn the argument of Jesus hates it
which he does and you know among
Christians as a moral argument I think
it's a very good one but in terms of
actually trying to get something done in
in real life that's not gonna do it the
you we literally cannot pass a law on
that basis that would be
unconstitutional now so what's the point
though so within what is I don't even
know what's the point of your arguments
the point of what you're saying I guess
it and I'm not trying to be cynical or
anything in interpreting what you're
doing here but it it does seem a little
bit like advertising your holiness
rather than actually trying to
accomplish something so that's my issue
when I advocate for a porn ban I don't
do it on religious basis I think you can
make the case without making it a
religious case and that's how it must be
approached if you actually want a chance
of it really happening
now as for the regulation regulation
part of this this goes to the question
of incremental gains should we as
conservatives seek incremental
improvements or should we insist on
total victory and reject smaller
victories until we get the big one we're
looking for those are the two options
now to me this is clear we meant we
maintain our principle position and our
opposition to the thing but we accept
incremental gains and improvements of
course we do if there was a twenty week
abortion ban that was about to be passed
in a state would you oppose it would you
actually oppose it would you say no I
don't want that that twenty week
abortion ban I guess you would you would
say better to have no abortion ban than
a 20-week ban but that's completely
unreasonable and counterproductive and
wrong I think because a twenty week
abortion ban isn't nearly good enough at
all I wouldn't be satisfied with it I
wouldn't be complacent about it but that
would save lives it would save a lot of
lives and so if you say I don't want
that you're throwing those lives out
you're saying they're not worth it to
save I'm not gonna let people die on the
basis of my you know all-or-nothing
principle I'm not gonna stamp my feet
and say no I won't accept this this
measure that will save lives
because it isn't everything I want I'm
not going to do that on porn
I want a ban yes but that's not
happening right now probably can't
happen right now considering Supreme
Court decisions that touch on this issue
it's very dubious whether a full-on ban
which is what I would like to see Abbott
could actually even pass so then what do
we do I'm a big believer in operating
within reality because we have no choice
but to do that right I still think we
should insist that a full band
ultimately in principle is right but why
not chip away at the problem if we can't
ban porn which we can't right now but we
can potentially protect millions of
eight-year-olds from seeing it from
being exposed to it and traumatized by
it why wouldn't we do that are you gonna
let those eight-year-olds get a get
exposed to porn on principle are you
gonna stand on principle and say well
yeah we could protect them we're not
going to though because it's not
everything we want if we can't protect
in the older people we're not gonna
protect the kids all or nothing you say
that regulations only make something
seem more acceptable I don't think
that's true smoking cigarette smoking is
much less common now than it used to be
I'm not saying that's all because of
regulations but it was regulated heavily
and the message was sent that this is a
bad dumb stupid thing to do and it's and
it's gonna get you killed and it is it's
now much less prevalent than it used to
be especially among younger people
younger people for the most part aren't
smoking cigarettes now they are still
smoking thing and they're smoking of
other things but sports fitness as far
as cigarettes go not nearly as common as
it used to be so I think your claim that
it's a that regulation is going to
automatically make the thing more
acceptable and more appealing in some
ways I don't think that holds up to
scrutiny I don't think it really works
that way the abortion industry is far
regulations ago they opposed regulation
now if regulations help them in some
send some sort of counterproductive way
for us you'd think that they would
embrace regulation they don't why why
don't they embrace it well because they
know that regulation is going to get in
the way it's gonna prevent them from
doing everything they want to do which
means ie
it's gonna save lives and they also know
that I think they know that the more
this thing is regulated and the more we
treat it like something potentially
dangerous and serious and harmful the
worse it's gonna be for them they want
it to be completely unregulated they
don't want regulations anywhere near it
because then they can present it as a
it's just a medical procedure no big
deal right just like get your tooth
pulled we don't need a ton of
regulations for that that's the way they
want to present it now you doing your
great work outside of the abortion
clinic the regulations that you run up
against are mostly like I'm sure I don't
have to tell you but the regulations
that are regulations on you telling you
that you can't be within X amount of
feet of the the
the of the abortion clinic and that sort
of thing now yes those are regulations
that that the abortion clinic is happy
about but but but those are regulations
meant to make it easier for them to do
their job so I think that's a totally
different scenario anyway thanks for all
your work do you do though in the
pro-life cause and we're certainly on
the same side and thanks for the email
and everyone have a great weekend
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor
Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there